Speaker 1: Closing the loop on a couple of other
stories. This is from like way. It's from the
weekend at CPAC in Texas a marjorie Taylor GREENE.
And actually, this may not have been at CPAC.
Maybe it is. Maybe it isn't. It was around
the time that CPAC took place. Marjorie Taylor
GREENE is insisting there were no Trump rioters on
January 6th. It was Antifa. But she also says that
the Trump people are being treated poorly by being
held in pretrial detention. Well, but so what?
Speaker 2: Real honest. I'm always
honest about it. I was upset that day.
I was a brand new member of Congress. I'd worked
very hard on objecting to Joe Biden's Electoral
College votes, because I believe that that was my
role and what I was what I wanted to do. And yeah.
Speaker 1: That was her desire.
Speaker 2: I believe it's the right thing.
I would do it today. I'd do it tomorrow. Oh, but
I was very upset. I never expected anything like
that. And when it happened, I thought, this is
the anti VA and no one can convince me it was
so-called Trump supporters. But and
we know there's a lot wrong there
and I cannot wait for a real investigation.
Speaker 3: Is that what's going to happen?
Speaker 2: Yeah, we will. They
will let me say that. So, yeah.
Speaker 1: And then Marjorie Taylor GREENE also
pointing out they will indeed do investigations
of the investigation into January 6th if they
get into power in November. That I believe her.
I do believe that she's actually telling the truth
about that. The weirdest thing about this is that.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE, on the one hand, wants
us to believe the people being investigated
and charged for the things they did on
January six, 2021, are being treated poorly
because they're Trump supporters. But at the
same time, she insists, they weren't really
Trump supporters. It was antifa, for which
of course, there is no evidence whatsoever.
So how could both be true? How could it be
that the Trump supporters didn't do anything
on January 6th? And also the Trump supporters from
January 6th aren't being treated correctly by the
justice system and by the jail system in which
they are being held in pretrial detention. Well,
I'm sure she can find some way to explain it
to people who pay no attention to reality.
It would probably be something like, well,
here's what happened. The vial is pretend I'm
a moron, right? Pretend I'm trying to figure out
a way to make both of these things plausible.
Here's the way that they would do it. There were
Trumpists in DC on January 6th, but none of them
committed any acts of violence or property
crime or anything. They weren't the rioters.
Antifa did the riots. And then law enforcement
arrested innocent Trump supporters who were
there just for the rally and is treating them
poorly in bad conditions. One guy without a vegan
food in pretrial detention. I think that's
the way someone like Marjorie Taylor GREENE
puts the two stories together. It
wasn't Antifa, it was Trump supporters